Thomas Jefferson was dubbed the Negro
president because of the extra 14
electoral votes he received as a result
of the three-fifths compromise from the
Constitutional Convention Pulitzer
prize-winning author Garry wills tells
the story in his new book this week's
public lives feature it's an hour I met
mr. wills in 1979 I'm ashamed to admit
that I haven't seen him since then and I
met him in 1979 because in that year we
persuaded him to come down and give the
principal address at the Fall
Convocation at the University it was a
lucky occasion for a distinguished
visitor and an eloquent address and mr.
wills
I checked I checked files on that
memorable occasion there's a complete
file everything notes whatever except
the speech if you've still got a copy
any rate it was a lucky occasion for us
a most distinguished mr. and a very
eloquent address I don't remember if it
was mr. wills fresh visit to the
University I think probably not but it
is nice to speculate that standing at
the podium under the portico of Cabell
Hall on that fall morning with the
matchless view of the lawn and the
Rotunda in front of him
the notion of writing a book on the
architecture of the university was born
speculation aside his excellent work mr.
Jabez university was published last year
as well as being a good book it has been
an extremely it has been extremely
popular among alumni which is all always
goodbye
because it evokes for everyone memories
of purple shadows on the lawn and all
that goes with it in his preface to his
newest book which of course he will talk
about this evening mr. Willis says and I
quote I have admired javis in all my
life and still do with this book he has
published now three books of a javasan
and a number of articles about him but
his total output of books and articles
which is truly staggering and I tried to
count how many books he has published
and I had sort of lost track somewhere
about 20 every covers a huge range of
subjects and I think it's indicative of
the breadth of his intellect and his
interest he is one that Pilon surprised
and he is one to national a book
National Book Awards and in 1998 he won
the National Medal for the humanities he
has held numerous academic appointments
and at present he is an adjunct
professor of history at Northwestern
University it is a great pleasure to
welcome Garry wills once another
scholarship
well thank you I've been coming here for
40 years and loving it every time
tonight I'd like to talk about the power
of the South which is an amazing thing I
thought I knew a lot about the South
both sides of my family come from the
south my father from Virginia and my
mother from Georgia and I was born in
Atlanta I grew up in Michigan but we
came back to visit the relatives all the
time in Norfolk and Atlanta and
Louisville and Birmingham and when the
civil-rights came along I interviewed a
lot of southerners Jimmy Carter and
Andrew Young and George Wallace and
David Duke and I've written about three
southern presidents but I was
nonetheless surprised and I guess
dumbfounded to read not long ago two
years or so ago the historian Richard
Brown saying from the inauguration of
George Washington until the beginning of
the Civil War the South was in the
saddle of American politics that is the
most important fact about the political
history of the early republic and I
thought even even though I thought I was
familiar that's astounding how did they
do that the North had more people more
money more prosperous banks and ports
manufacturers more prestigious
universities and authors and yet the
South could control the whole nation up
until the Civil War how could that be
now others have addressed this problem
and they've given various answers one of
the most common is that the South had a
very clear picture of what its interest
was what it needed from the federal
government and what it needed to deny to
the federal government and other parts
of the country the northern and eastern
parts had class conflict sectional
conflict religious conflict etc no
overriding one single issue the South
did not really have class conflict
because the poor whites had to be
supporters of the plantation class
because only they could make them safe
from slave rebellion and unrest and
besides they were able to take advantage
of various aspects of slavery and they
were part of the privileged class to be
white was to be part of the privileged
class no matter how poor you were and a
great deal of the camaraderie of the
South came from that fact that we were
all in it together so they voted
insistently and urgently together as a
bloc and that explains something but not
enough how did they overcome the
numerical disparity they made up when
they went to Philadelphia to the
Constitutional Convention 40% of the
free white population 40 to 60 well they
decided the only way they could deal
with this is change the count we're only
40 percent and we don't trust you to
deal fairly with us and so we've got to
even the numbers how do you do that
count our blacks as part of the
population that will be represented in
Congress and the north of course said we
can't do that they won't be really
represented they'll be counted but they
won't vote and you won't vote their
interests you'll vote against their
interest it's immoral it rewards you for
having slaves it gives you an incentive
to have more slaves so no we can't do it
and the answer of the South especially
the cotton states and the
lower South was take it or leave it
if you don't count them we're not coming
in and so the North in people like James
Wilson governor Morris and others said
this is immoral but we've got to
establish the Union we're falling apart
as a country
there will be no country shortly unless
we do something to create the Union
so we'll swallow some of this at least
and they come back and they say well we
can't count them all we'll count half
and the South says no no no that's not
good enough you gotta count at least
three quarters and so they bargain in
the bargain and they they had done this
already before and the Articles of
Confederation and finally 3/5 is the
compromise between 1/2 and 3/4 so it'll
be 3/5 will be counted and that goes
into the Constitution the people in the
North we're on the set you know this was
a compromise and what we hear about
compromises we hear just now about the
Medicare compromises if both sides are
unsatisfied it's a good deal that's
really not true both sides were
unsatisfied the North was not satisfied
because they're giving a power that was
not earned in any way and the South was
not satisfied because they didn't get
the full count if the if there had been
a full count it would have been about
50/50 split with only 3/5 it was about a
46:54 split so in ratification
conventions in the north and south there
was protests against this in the north
they said why should we do this and the
answer was well get the get the
government going and maybe we can amend
the Constitution we can do something to
ameliorate the problem but we've got to
get the government going in the south it
was wait a minute we're still not equal
why should we go in and Madison wrote to
Washington and others we're not equal
now but we soon will be the trend of the
popular
is down toward us and soon we will not
only be equal but we will be the
majority so in both cases although they
were none unsatisfied they went ahead
and did it the North turned out to be
the most unsatisfied for the long term
and no wonder three-fifths counting
three-fifths meant if I'm a northerner
and I vote for the congressperson man as
I should say at that time I'm
representing myself and my immediate
family wife and children was supposed to
be represented in the male vote and
that's all but if a southerner who owned
slaves votes he represents not only his
wife and family but let's say you old
ins 50 slaves he gets 30 extra votes
he's got 31 votes to my one what if he
owns 200 slaves like Jefferson he gets
120 votes to my 121 with his own what if
he owns 300 slaves like George
Washington he gets 180 votes to my one
not a good deal and that meant and would
mean for the whole history up to 1860
that the southern states always had a
third more representation in Congress
than their white free population
deserved well there was trouble ahead
obviously and the first signal of
trouble was 1796 when Jefferson first
ran for president and it looked like he
might win but only because of the
cushion given him by the three-fifths
count because the Electoral College is
based on the Congressional count so if
you have 1/3 more in the Congress you
have 1/3 more in the electoral college
and Oliver Wolcott who would become who
would become the governor of Connecticut
said if he wins but only by the Negro
count we should leave this arrangement
we have no equality this is not a
democracy but he didn't win in 1796 in
1800 however he did he won by eight
votes in the electoral college by that
time the south had 14 extra votes in the
electra college and he won 12 of them
which means John Adams won the election
in terms of free votes cast he won only
because of that three-fifths count and
that it's at that point that Timothy
Pickering and other Federalist leaders
started calling him the Negro president
he's not a real president he's a
president only because he owns Negroes
he was born into the temple of Liberty
on the shoulders of Negro slaves as the
way they put it well they saw even more
trouble ahead as they looked forward to
the next election in 18:4 they saw the
the 14 votes growing to 16 eventually
would grow to 19 to 20 and not only that
3 years after the 1800 election the
opportunity to purchase Louisiana came
up and Jefferson said yes well we'll buy
Louisiana and everybody thought if this
is a great deal and it was about the
Federalist friends of Pickering in
Connecticut in Massachusetts
especially in New Hampshire said wait a
minute now you're gonna add a whole tier
of southern plantation states all having
the three-fifths count added to them and
they said well you've destroyed the
rationale of the 3/5 count the 3/5 count
was originally to strike a kind of rough
parity between the north and south and
the original thirteen states now it's no
longer a matter of parity it's a
disparity and so you should do one of
three things you should either amend the
Constitution and take out the 3/5 clause
or not extend the 3/5 clause into the
New Territories because they were not
part of that original deal or you should
not extend slavery into the New
Territories but of course there's no way
that they could have made that work
because the three-fifths clause gave the
South the power to quash all such
movements it was a vicious circle and it
would continue to be that when there was
a question of adding the conquered
territories of Mexico which would have
added by the three-fifths margin the
three-fifths margin was the only thing
that made them able to vote that it was
a you because of the three-fifths margin
you can vote to add new territories
which will have the three-fifths margin
the disparity was such that I can't
remember numbers ought to read them to
you the slave states had 47 seats
instead of 33 because of the 3/5 count
in 1790 376 instead of 59 in 1812 98
instead of 73 in 1833 the three-fifths
rule would also play a decisive role in
every political caucus and every
political convention of the Democratic
Jeffersonians which meant not only that
they won votes in Congress over and over
and over by that but they were able to
put candidates in and block candidates
out because of that which would affect
the presidency we ended up with 12
slaveholding presidents and the Senate
confirmation of various Supreme Court
justices a majority of the Supreme Court
justices up until the Civil War we're
not only southerners or people who voted
with slavery they were slaveholders
people who themselves owned slaves the
majority of those who decided the Dred
Scott decision
of course voted the way they did they
own slaves themselves in the 62 years
between Washington's election and the
compromise of 1850 slaveholders not
southerners slaveholders controlled the
presidency for 50 years the speaker's
chair for 41 years the chairmanship of
the House Ways and Means Committee the
most important committee then for 42
years the only men to be reelected
President Washington Jefferson madison
monroe jackson were all slaveholders the
men who sat in the speaker's chair the
longest Andrew clay Andrew Stevenson
Nathaniel Macon were slaveholders 18 out
of 31 Supreme Court justices a majority
were slaveholders
so what Richard Brown said that
surprised me is obviously true they were
in the saddle they controlled the whole
trend of our politics in that period not
only because of the three-fifths clause
given that boost they were able to do a
number of other things for instance
going back to the very early days the
first Congress was set up by conjecture
because there was no census there was a
war going on you couldn't take a census
and so they estimated what were the
numbers but in 1790 there was a census
and they said now we can have a more
accurate count of what each state should
be how it should be represented in the
Congress when Congress passed a law that
said we've taken the total number of
citizens according to the census and we
have divided it up among the states and
where there are since the representation
was thirty thousand to one where there
are more than thirty thousand we have
rounded down or rounded up according to
whether they were closer to the higher
number or the lower number so if there
are fifty thousand an increment we would
round it up 60 and if there were less
than that threes rounded
2:30 and they passed this law and
Jefferson looked at it and said oh oh
we're gonna lose 4 votes in Congress so
he went to Washington said you've got to
cast the very first veto in the history
of this Republic to get rid of this
because otherwise the North is going to
creep up on us and Washington said well
this'll look to sectarians too much of
favoritism he said doesn't matter it
doesn't matter said we've got to pass a
law that if the count is above 30,000 in
any increment nothing above that will
count so if it's 50,000 we'll be brought
back down to 30,000 and they did that
which meant of course that there were
fewer people in Congress than the
population warranted but he had looked
at the figures state by state and they
knew if we do this those 40 those four
new votes will be canceled and so
Washington vetoed it and that was done
this is part of the the whole ongoing
effort to strengthen the slave interest
another one came after Washington was
president and when Jefferson became
president almost instantly when he did
he overturned something that the Adams
administration had proposed and followed
through on Toussaint L'Ouverture the
rebel in santa mang which is now Haiti
had overthrown the white plantation
class and Timothy Pickering as Secretary
of State had favored that move for a
number of reasons
he was an abolitionist and sent the
United States Navy down to help to San
win his revolution when Washington came
when Jefferson came in a year and a half
later he instantly canceled diplomatic
recognition of Tucson and he told
Napoleon's representative if you want to
crush to sand we will help you we will
supply you and we will starve to San
this was because his constituents and
the whole South was very upset that a
slave rebellion that close to our shores
would encourage an invitation among our
own people the South lived in a
perpetual panic about slave rebellion
and interference in slavery Jefferson
over and over had to reflect that he had
to represent his people for instance at
the time of the first Northwest
Ordinance which he drafted in the
Articles period he said there should be
no slavery in the Northwest Territories
and a lot of people give him credit for
doing that and probably rightly although
he said you can have them for 30 years
and then take him away which of course
would never have happened but after the
Constitution went into effect he changed
his mind entirely and he said we can
never have a restriction of slavery in
those territories why did he do that
well under the Articles every state had
one vote
it didn't matter whether you had slaves
or not few slaves many slaves etc it
didn't affect representation you had
only one vote after the Constitution
came into effect in there was
proportionate representation the
three-fifths clause gave any slave state
an extra bonus of 1/3 more and that's
when he changed his tune and he said no
the federal government has no power to
restrict slavery in the territories not
only that when he was building his
magnificent university which I revere
and wrote a book to prove he said to his
coadjutor in the legislature of the
state we've got to get the money to
finish this university right away
our people our sons are going to Harvard
and Princeton and Yale
and they're being taught restriction ISM
that the federal government has the
power to restrict slavery we've got to
keep them here and teach them the true
doctrine now was all of this racist in
the sense that he hated blacks I don't
think so he he was defending what was
essential to the southern way of life it
was essential to their economic
existence it was essential to their
political existence it was essential to
their ideological framework to their own
self-esteem
he had many ways of justifying this to
himself and others others had different
ways many tried to use the Bible to say
you know slavery is OK according to the
Bible
some said slavery is actually not an
evil it's a good Jefferson never said
that he said it isn't evil and we'd like
to get rid of it but for now we can't
and we have these counterbalancing goods
we have agrarian virtue with its admit
admittedly we have some slavery and
that's not too good but we don't have
cities we don't have banks we don't have
commerce so we don't have credit we
don't have trade we don't have
manufacture and everybody knows that
those are the source of evil and the
only natural life for human beings is to
live close to the soil close to nature
to be a yeoman farmer with agrarian
virtue
now that's a long traditions view comes
from the classic Greek and Roman times
and was being proposed by physiocrats in
France and others at the time when
Jefferson said that but most people met
by agrarian virtue the independent
farmer on his own land
and Jefferson of course meant the garyun
capitalist with a slave labor force it's
quite quite a difference but he tried to
rationalize it to himself I'm sure and
to others and he's convinced an awful
lot of people so that one of the things
that I run into constantly now that I've
published this book is why have we not
learned anything about this why you know
why is agrarian virtue matter but the
three-fifths Clause doesn't matter
that's a good question
in fact just recently a very prominent
historian Joyce Appleby defended the
three-fifths clause she said it didn't
matter that blacks were counted but
couldn't vote because after all women
and children were counted among the
whites and they couldn't vote of course
the man who was voting for them
consulted their interests the person who
was voting for the black count was using
it against them as using the
three-fifths clause to extend slavery to
protect slavery but think of it a
prominent historian can still think that
even today she said three-fifths should
not have been counted five fifths should
have been counted you know which would
have given Jefferson not only 120 votes
extra but 200 extra votes that's how
blind we had been to the importance of
slavery and the importance of the whole
southern strategy of using everything
including the three-fifths clause to
protect an endangered situation
endangered internally externally
domestically internationally slavery was
a doomed institution in the early 19th
century it was being abolished around
the world the northern states which had
put up with it we're getting rid of it
the abolitionists were becoming more and
more perturbed at the immorality of it
and so they they
figured they were in the fight for their
life and they were and the best example
of that is the gag rules what had been
said whenever any abolitionist brought
up dealing with slavery in the States
was you can't it's protected in the
states the Constitution gives the only
jurisdiction over slavery to the states
federal government has no jurisdiction
and everybody admitted that including
Abraham Lincoln in 1858
but the abolitionists said what about
the District of Columbia that is
entirely under the jurisdiction of
Congress and nobody else's so we can
discuss getting rid of slavery in the
District of Columbia and the southerners
who were as I say panicky about this
whole issue said no no no you can't do
that it will overthrow our whole way of
life it will encourage slave rebellions
in the neighboring states in Millett
Maryland and in Virginia you cannot even
discuss it and in 1836 and 1838 they
brought in a rule saying that and then
with the help of their democratic
northern partners as well as the
three-fifths clause they imposed it in
1840 the North had finally realized this
is ridiculous we are making Congress
deny themselves First Amendment rights
that belong to all citizens that they
can't even have free speech to discuss
slavery so they stopped voting for it
but in 1840 it passed again why the
three-fifths clause that was the margin
in 1842 it passed again the three-fifths
clause over and over when they had
nothing left they could fall back on
that terrible weapon that was given them
by the Constitution it was a far more
terrible weapon even than the 20-year
extension of the international slave
trade which most southerners wanted to
get rid of anyway because it drove down
the prices of slaves more than the
Fugitive Slave Law because this went
right to the heart of whether you could
even discuss the matter
with ourselves so it's an astonishing
thing that we have avoided looking at
this for so long we've avoided looking
at a lot of aspects of slavery we are
doing it now the human rights revolution
of the last part of the 20th century has
made us look at rights not only of
slaves but of women and gays and ethnic
minorities religious minorities etc
there's now a wonderful wave of people
wanting to look at this monticello
itself is a model of this when I first
went there 40 years ago that the slaves
were servants they they loved their
master and masters loved them and all of
that kind of thing you don't hear that
anymore you now hear an honest story but
some people have said can we afford to
be honest can we afford to say this
about our sacred founders well I think
we can't afford not to we have to be
honest and it shows a lack of confidence
in them that we think they can't stand
the truth I think they can I think
Jefferson can I think there are all
kinds of things about Jefferson and the
other founders that are very important
and that we can honor I think that's
true
Henry windsock who's here has written a
wonderful book about George Washington
which shows how horrible was his control
of slaves early on and he learned
something about that and and changed to
some degree more than Jefferson did but
all of the founders were tainted by this
and not only all of the southerners the
North was complicit Abraham Lincoln is
right in the second inaugural address
that this is a sin of the nation we were
all involved in it we all are paying the
price in the Civil War can we afford to
be honest about our founders of course
we can
this is something we all have a very
personal experience of when we are born
we're very tiny and our parents are huge
they're very big and they're very
powerful it seems they're very they know
a lot and as we grow up we learn that
well they're not they can't do
everything and they don't know
everything and as we grow up a little
more we find out well as a matter of
fact they got an awful lot of flaws
which we can identify because we have a
lot of them too but coming to maturity
as a person means facing the truth about
your parents on the way to facing the
truth about yourselves of course and
still honoring them and esteeming them
and loving them for what they have done
for you and I think the same thing is
true of us as a nation we've had a sappy
cult of the founders which is an insult
to them and to us we don't deserve to be
such idiots but we can face the truth
and honor them and learn to make
ourselves better in the process and it's
about time
while mr. wills gets his drink of water
and prepares to answer our questions I
remind you again to please have your
questions well-structured and succinct
and if you have a question please come
here to the microphone we might be able
to hear you in the room but c-span is
wired to this mic as well yes sir yes
how do you justify explain the Amistad
opinion of that Supreme Court not going
down the same road as the Dred Scott
decision well of course that's a
different thing to the foreign right I'm
a statin vial of foreign rights not
domestic rights over slavery and I
justified that by the fact that John
Quincy Adams and a lot of other people
put up a terrific defense but we can't
bail them out just on that it would have
if they had not gone along with that it
would have been really horrible the
interesting thing is that John Quincy
Adams had a terrible record on slavery
up until the time he left the White
House and went into the Congress and
then he became terrific and the
interesting thing is that he had fought
Timothy Pickering all their careers and
Pickering is dead by then he picked up
every one of Pickering's causes amend
the Constitution to get rid of the
three-fifths if you won't do that will
threaten to secede all of those things
that Pickering had done and got no
credit for John Quincy Adams gets credit
for in his last 14 years of his life and
deserves but Timothy Pickering also
deserves some credit someone else
yes please are you holiday thank you
you're welcome
ah I was thinking as you talked about
the power of the South in slavery in
terms of the power of the South that has
extended fall beyond slavery yes I
recall when I was in the military just
before the Caribbean war and during that
war that even though I took my basic
training in Fort Dix New Jersey that the
South had the power to determine what
would be the nature of the relationship
of black and white soldiers in the north
and even northern people who had gone to
school in New York were very integrated
they were segregated in the north
because the south had that kind of power
and the course it still has it today
and so that legacy is still real but you
mentioned one keyword which is
complicity and I have a feeling and I
just want you to comment on that that
the real reason the South had the power
to do what it did if you call there's
not much difference in what the nollans
believed and advocated and sometime use
of excuse when really it was the the
whole nation and not just the South I
agree on the other hand to be complicit
in it was not to be equally guilty there
were of course massive groups trying to
free the slaves
in the north there weren't in the south
and there couldn't be they say silence
them and they threw out abolitionists
who came into the South and they threw
out abolitionist literature that came
into the south so there was complicity
but there was not equal guilt but you're
quite right that ending slavery
certainly didn't end racism by no means
see the the unique situation of America
is that as the southerners rightly said
there was slavery in ancient Greece
there's slavery slavery in ancient Rome
there was slavery in medieval Europe
Pope's had slaves right into the
Renaissance slavery was a constant of
human history but it was normally slaves
who were not racially differential
differentiated from their owners the
normal way of enslaving at that time was
conquest the conquered people you'd free
ssam you'd sell some and keep some as
slaves but in America the racial part of
slavery was pinned so closely to it that
when you got rid of slavery you didn't
get rid of racism many of abolitionists
themselves thought there shouldn't be
slavery but blacks are not equal
they were not for the black having the
vote certainly they're not for things
like intermarriage so the North fought
with one hand behind its back as it were
and that's why reconstruction was
defeated
that's why Jim Crow could be re-imposed
that's why the civil rights movement had
to fight and fight and fight to get even
basic decencies and that's why once
that's done the battles not over we're
still going on with fights over racism
the solid south which was so solid in
slavery has been solid ever since it was
solid Democratic when the Democratic
Party looked the other way about racism
and it switched right away to a solid
Republican when the Democrats stopped
doing that remember Franklin Delano
Roosevelt had to deal with the southern
chairman in the south if nothing else
they have a wonderful sense of
self-preservation it voted in and again
again and again all these people who
built up their seniority and they
controlled all the chairmanships of
Congress and so when in 1938 people
wanted to put in up in 1936 they wanted
to put in a anti lynch platform and the
Democratic Party Roosevelt sent signal
you can't do that I need those son and
chairman I can't have the New Deal
without them
so racism continues to this day it's
continues and things like flying the
Confederate flag and saying it has
nothing to do with slavery that's like
saying the skull and crossbones has
nothing to do with piracy of course it
has to do with slavery it was not about
tariffs it was not about severa the
states rights and the proof of that is
that not only were the gagged laws to
impose on the whole nation but anybody
who went into the South and the
preceding years before the Civil War and
tried to advocate the freeing of slaves
was beaten tarred and feathered run out
of town and even literature would not be
allowed in they interfered with the
United States mail you know Pat Buchanan
people like say like these were freedom
fighters they were opposing the despotic
federal government they were the ones
who are imposing despotism in South
Carolina they went out on to the boats
in Charleston and they would find
abolitionist literature and throw it in
the bay even though it's coming in
through the United States mail and the
postmasters wrote to Andrew Jackson said
we can't really destroy the United
States mail can we he said no that's
true darn it we can't but we can deliver
it to the post office and not deliver it
to the people but post their names and
say if you want to pick up your mail
come and pick it up at the post office
and keep their names posted as a sign of
infamy now to say that slavery was not
the issue and when a president United
States is using the United States mail
to vilify anybody who wants to even
think or write or propose about slavery
is to be absolutely blind
I've always been fascinated by this
banning of slavery from the Northwest
Territories and it seems why if the
South was so powerful at that time and
they were why they almost so blithely
just went along with it and why given
that it was clearly something that was
going to down the road alter the balance
within the Union and also did they ever
did anyone ever muse any southerners
ever muse about reopening the question
oh sure you have to go into why to the
extent to which it was okay there was
okay done to the Articles remember that
it was not okayed under the Constitution
under the Articles there was only one
vote per state remember this is a last
minute Congress that was still operating
under the rules of the Articles and they
didn't know that the Constitution was
going to be successfully drafted and
they certainly didn't know there was
going to be successfully ratified and it
was almost not so to the extent that
they went along with it it was a quite
different thing from the way that it
actually developed and as I say
Jefferson had proposed it with a 30-year
interval Timothy Pickering had proposed
a year earlier without that interval and
he never gets any credit for that
Jefferson is always given credit for the
Northwest Ordinance keeping slavery out
and Timothy Pickering had proposed a
year earlier any attack Jefferson's plan
when it came because of that 30-year
margin so it was not a self-denying
ordinance by any means what do you think
would have happened if they hadn't come
up with a three-fifths compromise would
there have been a Constitution no no
there wouldn't remember the Constitution
barely squeaked by it was opposed very
strenuously in most states and only at
the last minute did New York for
instance come in saying well we can't
stay out if they're all ready to do it
but we demand these and these in these
Massachusetts did the same thing all
those demands for Bill of Rights were
part of that it was a very close call
if Washington had not backed it it would
not have passed
perhaps if Franklin had not backed it it
would wouldn't have passed remember this
was an immensely risky thing when
Washington was asked to go the first
time to the Philadelphia Convention he
said no for several reasons but not only
that he he wrote to Franklin and said
you shouldn't go either your reputation
is a very important national asset and
if you go to this it would be destroyed
and the reason he thought that is that
he wrote to John J and said if we do
anything real there we will be traitors
won't we and John J said yeah remember
you could not change the Constitution
except which were they called the
Articles except unanimously and
everybody was sent by their state as
delegates with instructions to amend the
Articles and the only way you could do
that is to get a unanimous vote they
came up with the idea No nine states
will be enough which was breaking the
articles and what they had to do then is
go into secret session very secret they
went upstairs they've kind of bound
themselves to secrecy and if that did
come out what they were doing state
after state would have withdrawn their
delegates for breaking the instructions
Washington presided over this secrecy
and was adamant about it and there's a
great story of I think it was the
Georgia delegate who came in one day and
after a lunch break and Washington said
he they sat in committee of the whole
normally and he went back into committee
the regular committee where he was the
president and said somebody has betrayed
us
they have left notes out during the
lunch period if those are yet if those
were picked up by someone that could
have destroyed our whole effort he said
here they are on the table
whoever owns them should reclaim them
the Georgia delegates that nobody had
the nerve to and when it was published
you know a number of people said the
dark Conclave came up with a treasonous
thing and the one argument that could be
used over and over is that how could it
be treasonous if George Washington and
Benjamin Franklin are behind it and the
Federalists the anti-federalists people
said these are Trojan horse names
they're the ones that are smuggling in
this horrible thing these the magic of
great names is being used against us and
it was if if Washington hadn't risked
his reputation I think it's the most
heroic thing he did in his life he knew
that if this failed everything he had
done up to that point it would be
totally blackened and if he hadn't done
it we wouldn't have had a constitution
your discussion of the power of this
three-fifths compromise seems to me and
I should add I was once an American
historian it seems so obvious that I
wonder if you I mean it just I read it
and I thought why didn't anybody ever
say this before in such a big and public
way I'm sure you have some theories
about that and I'd like to know yes it
is astonishing it's absolutely
astonishing as I say Joyce Appleby just
recently wrote in a way that shows she
had no grasp of what it meant to look at
this we have to see how our country over
a whole range of issues over a whole
range of years has shied away from
hidden from disguise the impact of
slavery in all of its aspects we have
not wanted to face up to it we have
bought a lot of the myths of the south
northern is by all these myths
paternalism and fine old magnolia charm
and all of that you know if you go to
Gettysburg
they sell uniforms for the little kids
and
the Confederate uniforms outsell the
unity Union uniforms 5 6 7 2 1 now
because they're all southerners there
but because the myth of the South is
such the romance of robert e lee and all
of these great heroes and the south
lives with that and the North puts up
with it as I told you at the beginning
all my relatives are from the south and
they all believe this stuff they
couldn't understand why I did not
there's a wonderful book by Tony
Horovitz called
Confederates in the Attic he went with
his father who liked to do these battle
reconstructions and he started talking
to some of these Confederates and of
course in the battle reconstructions you
have everybody wanted to be on the
Confederate side nobody on the Union
side and so we found all these people
and so he went he was intrigued and he
went back to their states and he started
interviewing people at the local
Historical Society's and found relics of
all of the great leaders including many
great clan leaders and the whole idea
that the Ku Klux Klan whether for
freedom fighters all of that stuff lives
and the North either pays no attention
to that or thinks it's unimportant or
goes along with it we haven't faced up
to slavery and they were very good at
marginalizing people as extremists and
radicals
you know the abolitionists were all
radicals the reconstruction people were
all radicals the people who tried to
promote civil rights in the 50s and 60s
we're outside agitators radicals
communists socialists they believed that
and they and doesn't seem to upset a lot
of people that's a very sad thing but on
but I think it's changing I think as
I've said before the history of slavery
is now being written in every history
department in America it's being
recognized not only in Monticello but in
Mount Vernon Williamsburg other places
and it's part of a general revolution in
human rights you know the the greatest
change in our lifetime
is the one that it finally after all
these years for the first time in any
culture recognizes the Equality of women
that's such a breakthrough that equality
for everybody else almost has to come
along with it eventually it's a fight
it's always a fight but we've but we're
not we're not at all in the situation of
people forty years ago say this has been
an extraordinary time that's a exciting
time we are recognizing a lot about
ourselves as a country in our history
one more question
yes Jefferson used the argument of
states rights and actually how
deliberate was that as a political
strategy and that's that's the first
part of my question how deliberate was a
political mask for what he really wanted
and then to what extent do you feel that
he came to really blatantly contradict
his ideals for public education at the
university by trying to turn it into a
bulwark a bulwark of of states rights
well he did believe in states rights and
not only because of slavery because the
most intense conflict of course was not
over slavery at all but was over the
Alien and Sedition laws where he thought
that the Adams administration was
becoming despotic and proposed rebellion
non obedience intervention so that was a
that was a sincere part of his life
sometimes it worked together with
slavery sometimes it didn't I don't want
to reduce everything about him to the
issue of slavery it was always there
slavery was on the minds of slaveholders
24 hours a day they
lived with it they knew its dangers they
wanted to protect their own people from
it
they knew that others were shaming them
you know the most a man who tried to
live a halfway decent life as a
plantation owner had always the
contagion of a lot of people who didn't
a lot of plantation owners who didn't so
it was a constant struggle but
nonetheless there were other issues
there was religious freedom there was
local government which is a sincere
cause and has its own validity there was
intellectual freedom which he would
allow in other cases sometimes not in
the case of slavery so no I wouldn't say
that it was all hypocritical and all a
mask by any means and the University of
Virginia the protection of slavery was
one aspect out of a large program
largely wonderful and we we have to live
with both realities that's that's the
interesting thing about life that you
can't say he did one thing wrong so
everything was wrong or he did one thing
right and everything was right the
important thing when you have a cult of
people is to realize when and how badly
they committed truly evil things like
protecting slavery thank you so much mr.
Willis Gary wills is author of Negro
President Jefferson and the slave power
it's published by Houghton Mifflin on
the web at houghton mifflin books calm
next week on public lives ready for
revolution the autobiography of late
civil rights leaders Stokely Carmichael